la santé mentale c'est secondaire tant
qu'on a la santé
sauf que la santé c'est pas juste la
santé physique la santé mentale elle est
aussi importante d'ailleurs de toute
façon les deux sont complètement liés
donc être en bonne santé c'est être en
bonne santé physique et en bonne santé
mentale et on peut même rajouter la
santé sociale parce qu'elle est aussi
intimement liée aux deux autres on ne
peut pas être en bonne santé physique et
mentale si on souffre d'isolement social
ou de précarité on ne peut pas être en
bonne santé physique et sociale si on
est en mauvaise santé mentale vous avez
compris pour être en bonne santé il faut
que ces trois composantes soient bonnes
donc c'est au moins aussi important
d'aller consulter quand on a un coup de
pas bien psychologique que quand on a le
nez qui coule par exemple je le
répéterai jamais assez prenez votre
santé mentale au sérieux